bonsoir jean vincent bres et merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
la chine et les états unis qui ont
déclaré aujourd'hui vouloir vrai pour la
bonne conduite de cet accord
déjà ce qu'on peut lui croire à cette
bonne volonté selon vous bonne volonté
on peut forcer des deux côtés parce que
il ya eu un premier
ainsi pour faire un premier accord qui a
été fait au mois de janvier selon
laquelle la chine se donnait 50
d'obligations en particulier d'achat de
matériel américain produits américains
la suite n'a pas tout à fait tenu ses
obligations les états unis continuent un
petit peu le bras de fer avec la chine
cernés dans des négociations bilatérales
dur or des classiques des négociations
politiques alors un accord en tout cas
qualifiée d'historique par donald trump
eu à l'époque en janvier justement est
ce que aujourd'hui vous vous employez
aurait le même adjectif pour le
qualifier alors si c'est à voir jusqu'au
bout oui il sera historique dans la
mesure où la chine etats unis vont
établir et des relations beaucoup plus
forte
ce plan commercial est beaucoup plus
équilibré que tu es le seul à l'heure
actuelle à l'heure actuelle c'est quand
même la chine qui est le fournisseur des
états unis très largement les etats-unis
estiment ne pas pouvoir vendre
suffisamment la chine parce qu'il ya des
blocages de la part des chinois
si le blocage disparaissent en faveur
des états unis ça veut dire que
l'analyse des rivaux prendre des parts
de marché en particulier à l'europe il
ya ces fameux droits de douane punitifs
vous voudriez qu'elle est la principale
chose qui va changer avec cet accord les
clips va se rétablir réellement c'est
pas vraiment un équilibre simplement la
chine avec cet accord pour pouvoir
continuer à exporter vers les états unis
et pour pouvoir continuer à progresser
sur le plan technologique va être obligé
d'accepter d'acheter surtout américains
est bon ce sont les choix sont les choix
ou détriment encore une fois d'autres
d'autres pays qui vont des beaucoup
à la chine est tombée dessus ça veut
dire vous entendre que c'est un accord
plutôt gagnant gagnant entre la chine et
les états unis mais plutôt perdant
perdant pour d'autres pays lesquelles
par exemple l'europe et particulièrement
visés les agriculteurs européens en
particulier parce que les amis européens
vendait beaucoup à la chine l'allemagne
vendait des voitures et les
machines-outils enfin de bonne partie
des européens vont des broutilles âgées
et autres pour des sommes extrêmement
important vers la chine et tous ces pays
là vont se retrouver supplantés par les
firmes américaines dont les prix seront
peut-être un niveau différent pour les
chinois mais en échange de quoi les je
suis doit continuer à exporter des
produits finis en direction des états
unis
aujourd'hui quel est justement là le
moyen de réponse de répliques si j'ose
dire de ces pays européens la france
avec ses agriculteurs l'allemagne avec
ses vendeurs de voitures alors pour le
moment les moyens qu'on a vu se déployer
sont restés au niveau du discours et je
vois mal comment ça pourrait sortir du
niveau du discours parce que les pays
européens son système de négociation qui
est assistant de négociations un petit
peu classique
il était complètement dépassé dans le
bras de fer aux arômes qui se déroule
entre pékin et washington
est-ce que selon vous cela peut
améliorer les relations entre la chine
et les états unis de manière plus
politique où on reste vraiment dans un
cadre purement commerciale alors là je
pense que pour le moment réservé un
cadre purement commerciales et les etats
unis jouent un petit peu la force
il joue la force vis-à-vis langue ongles
vous en avait déjà parlé il tente de
jouer la force et vis-à-vis taiwan les
rapports des états unis et taiwan ont
évolué très très brutalement dans les
derniers jours simplement et très en
faveur de taïwan il faut pas oublier non
plus que les états unis ont des lois
qu'ils obligent à protéger taïwan
et que le concurrent de trump pour les
élections présidentielles promet une
politique encore plus dure vis-à-vis de
la chine
et puis cette présence américaine
permanente au nom de la liberté de
circulation en mer de chine du sud
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
très très dur pour les pour les chinois
alors les les promesses de campagne de
donald trump a on est à peu de temps de
l'élection présidentielle envers les
agriculteurs américains ce qu'elles ont
un peser selon vous les agriculteurs
américains forment quand même une bonne
partie il ya super intelligent qui
ferait du tort à presles val et
l'agriculteur américains sont plutôt
partie de l'électorat trump
il est évident que si les états unis
peuvent être les exportateurs privilégié
de produits agricoles en direction de la
chine
il est évident que ça ça va jouer en
faveur de notre hub le fait aussi que
bayonne soit présentée par les
républicains américains et par un
certain de services de renseignement
comme le préféré de pékin c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui joue en
faveur de ben laden bien au contraire
merci beaucoup à jean vincent brisset
d'avoir été avec mon chercheurs à
l'hélice merci à vous